et trouver un éclair une voix une voix à
la janis puissante et rocailleuse pour
te comprendre bien depuis quelques mois
manu lanvin répète ici tous les jours
chez lui l'un des titres phares de son
troisième album je lui dis report
un titre aux couleurs de rock et de
blues à la fois mélancolique et plein
d'espoir de chanter pour moi c'est comme
si je fume pas je meurs et nouvel album
avec 12 titres dont certains écrits par
un certain pierre billon célèbre
parolier des l'idée de sardou un nouvel
opus qui sera enregistré en studio dans
quelques jours avec des musiciens et pas
n'importe lesquels les renforts
de l'autre j'ai la chance d'avoir des
musiciens extraordinaires puisque ce
sont des musiciens qui jouent avec
arthur h avec charlie couture entre
autres voilà donc j'étais extrêmement
heureux qu'ils acceptent de travailler
sur ce projet compte c'est ici avec ses
amis parolier qu'il a écrit les textes
de son troisième album
c'est ici qu'il se ressource en plein
soleil là on est dans la campagne dans
la campagne mais tout près de la ville
de la pire là juste derrière c'est un
truc exceptionnel parce que c'est un
chêne d'amérique
voilà et j'ai cru comprendre que dans
notre région
c'était exceptionnel très très rare oui
elle
ici aussi qu'ils jouent les guitare à la
main et les titres de ses copains jamais
bien loin et l'enfer c'est bien comme un
espoir qui a tenté par un jeu que le
soir je veux partager autre chose que de
l'abondante son lit et entend de la vie
est le plus mais souffre et sotigui au
fil des filets pour moi
johnny tu l'as d'or c'est un pote à toi
non j'ai eu la chance de le rencontrer
deux fois
voilà et c'est un mec extraordinaire
super sympa et voilà elle puis ben dans
le milieu dans notre profession on
l'appelle le taulier et c'est pas pour
rien passé c'est le taulier quoi c'est
le boss